it's through she's connected by at t
that i'm able to impact the next
generation of young girls my coaching
style is positive good encouraging
that's good i would say i'm patient now
get to a side but i want a level of
accountability too
and i think the clear communication that
a coach can have with a player
when they understand what's required of
them what's expected of them then you
kind of have a baseline of
accountability and you can kind of build
up from there
i'm becky hammond i am originally from
rapid city south dakota went and played
in the wnba for 16 years after
retirement from my playing career i
became the coach with the san antonio
spurs and now i am head coach with the
las vegas aces this was an opportunity
for me to sit in the big chair and
be a head coach of a major professional
sports league i think it's vital for the
next generation to have role models
mentors
representation
my name is ryan forseer i am 15 years
old
hey ryan i play like a combo garden in
basketball hi today is very special
i get to spend the day with becky heaven
i would describe her as a goat a genius
i've never had anyone that high up take
the time to teach me and let me pick
their brain the mind's a powerful thing
it's informing not only your journey and
where you're headed but also how you
respond and interact with people on that
journey
pretty amazing to see yourself on a big
screen like that huh oh yeah i want to
have a move that is like my go-to that
gets someone every time all right let's
go yeah so a lot of times what happens
is players make this mistake so now you
be my defender
i just went like this and then i bring
it back here right in front of you and
that's where you get stripped when we
can connect with somebody and have that
moment to impact them or give them a
belief in themselves
we kind of keep it on the side that
really truly anything is possible
is a really powerful thing to give
another human being seeing myself on the
jumbotron and getting feedback from
becky that was like
how that's all i can explain it as it
was amazing i would say my career path
as a coach in the mba has definitely
challenged gender roles i think how we
change the mindset of the world is a
mind by mind moment let's respect each
other's skill set for what it is
when a little boy or a little girl comes
into this arena it's just as important
for little boys to see me out there so
now the parents are explaining to their
young boy or girl oh this is this is
so-and-so and she did this and now she's
a coach in the nba you could be a coach
in the nba too i think those are the
conversations that have to be had after
that you'll see more and more
opportunity open up
for young girls hopefully in
professional sports because there's room
at the table for everybody